بعد أسابيع قليلة من السقوط المأساوي
لأفغانستان ، حدث شيء مهم
في البلد الآخر حيث
أجرت أمريكا تجربة عظيمة لبناء الدولة
على مدى العقدين الماضيين ،
أجرى العراق انتخابات كانت في الغالب
حرة ونزيهة على افتراض أن هذه العملية
أدت إلى تشكيل حكومة جديدة.
سيكون
الانتقال السلمي السادس للسلطة منذ عام 2004.
على الرغم من أن الإقبال كان منخفضًا بشكل قياسي ، فإن
هذه الانتخابات تشير إلى تقدم حقيقي ،
وصفه مسؤول عراقي كبير لي
بأنه زلزال سياسي
تلخيصه بعد 18 عامًا من
الغزو الأمريكي الذي بشر بعهد من
الفوضى المدنية  صمدت الحرب وصعود
النظام الديمقراطي في العراق إلى
أن أصبحت الانتخابات روتينية
تتنافس فيها الأحزاب السياسية وتتاجر بالحصان ،
وهناك درجة من
وسائل الإعلام التعددية وقضاء حازم بشكل متزايد
ليس حرًا ومستقلًا تمامًا
وفقًا للمعايير الغربية ولكنه
يظهر بعض التقدم
ووصف المسؤول العراقي الكبير
النتائج بأنها زلزال سياسي
لأنه وصفهم
بأنهم هزيمة للميليشيات وانتصار
للدولة العراقية كما تراها بعد
ذوبان جيش العراق في أعقاب الغزو الأمريكي 2003
، أنشأ سماسرة السلطة السياسية والأحزاب الميليشيات المسلحة المملوكة لها
مع مرور الوقت
نمت قوة الميليشيات الشيعية بشكل خاص.
عندما تمت دعوتهم لمحاربة تنظيم الدولة
وأصبحوا نوعًا من الدولة الموازية
الخاصة بهم ،
كان العديد منهم على صلة وثيقة بإيران ، ولكن في هذه
الانتخابات من قبل أحد الأحزاب التي تضم
ميليشيات ، انتقلت من 45 مقعدًا إلى أقل من 20 مقعدًا.
كان صعود
المشاركة
السنية من السنة ، كانت الأقلية في
العراق الأكثر استياءًا داخل
النظام السياسي ، كانوا يميلون إلى
السخرية من التصويت ، وما زالوا
ساخطين
في الماضي ، لقد قاموا في بعض الأحيان بتأجيج
حركات التمرد
ولكن هذه المرة صوتوا لإدارة
لتركيز أصواتهم في عدد أقل من الأحزاب ،
سأراقب التقديرات بأنه إذا تمكن عدد قليل من
هؤلاء القادة من
توحيد كتلة سنية موحدة مع  سيحصل على 50 مقعدًا
في برلمان العراق البالغ عدد مقاعده 329 مقعدًا ، الأمر الذي
سيمنحه قوة سياسية أكبر
مما كان عليه منذ عام 2003.
الفائز الأكبر في هذه الانتخابات هو
مقتدى
رجل الدين الراديكالي المناهض لأمريكا
الذي قاتلت مليشياته القوات الأمريكية
في الماضي
الآن ولكن سردار لديه  حول
نفسه إلى لاعب سياسي
يعمل داخل النظام العراقي ،
فإن صعوده إلى السلطة يمكن أن يجبره الآن على
حل بعض ميليشياته
ودعم الدولة بقوة أكبر ،
وهناك إشارات على أنه سيفعل ذلك
المحزن المثير للاهتمام الذي نجح في هذه
الانتخابات من خلال-  صُمم
تنظيم الجهود الشعبية واستراتيجية
تواصل ذكية استشرافية ،
واستخدم حزبه قوانين الانتخابات الجديدة
بفعالية وأنشأ بالفعل
تطبيقًا يخبر مؤيديه أين
ومتى يصوتون ، وبالتالي فإن توزيع
الأصوات بكفاءة للحصول على أقصى قدر من التمثيل قد
قطع مقتدى الصدر شوطًا طويلاً  من
أيامه كثوري عنيف
ويتولى تدريجياً دور زعيم حاذق
للحزب
الخلاصة الثالثة من الانتخابات هي
أنه على الرغم من النفوذ السياسي والعسكري الديني
الإيراني في الأحزاب العراقية الموالية لإيران ، إلا
أن نفس المسؤول العراقي الكبير قال
أي شيء آخر قد يقوله المرء عن
مقتدى الصدر ، فمن الواضح أنه
قومي عراقي لا يفعل ذلك.  مثل أي
تدخل أجنبي من أي جانب
في البلاد ،
سألت المسؤول ما الذي يفسر
النجاح النسبي للعراق ، وهو
أول من يعترف بأنه نسبي
ومبدئي ، وأشار إلى عاملين كبيرين
أولاً بعد الفشل الذريع لسياسات أمريكا
المبكرة في العراق.
لدمج جميع المجموعات في
النظام السياسي
، قال إن أحد النجاحات غير
المعلنة للاندفاع بقيادة
الزوجين الغريبين العظيمين ديفيد بترايوس
وراي أوديرنو كان إعادة العديد من
الميليشيات السنية إلى الحظيرة
حيث كان التواصل السياسي في
تناقض ملحوظ مع  السياسة في أفغانستان التي
استبعدت منذ البداية أي
مشاركة لطالبان في النظام
السياسي  ثانيًا ، قال إنها
المعركة ضد تنظيم الدولة
التي جمعت البلاد حقًا
، قال إن العراق كان دائمًا لديه
شعور بأنه أمة ونظام حكم ، لكن
هذا عمّق تلك الهوية وعندما
انتصرنا أعطانا جميعًا الفخر بهذا
الإنجاز ، يحذر المسؤولون من ذلك.
لا تزال ديمقراطية العراق هشة. الفساد
يقوض شرعية الدولة
والنظام السياسي
في الوقت الحالي. قال إن التحدي الملح هو
أن الخاسرين في هذه الانتخابات عليهم
قبول خسارتهم وعدم اللجوء إلى
العنف أو الوسائل الدستورية الإضافية ،
لكنه يرى بوادر مشجعة.
لقد تعلم العراقيون أنه ليس لدينا
بديل سوى التعامل مع خلافاتنا من
خلال
السياسة للثقة في الانتخابات وقبل كل شيء
للتسوية والتسوية
، يجب على الخاسرين قبول خسارتهم
ويجب على جميع الأطراف التنازل عن من
كان يتخيل قبل عقد من الزمان
أن السياسة العراقية قد توفر بعض
دروس مفيدة للديمقراطية الأمريكية